au domaine de dampierre en yvelines on
remonte dans le temps
nous sommes en 1748 louis 15 et madame
de pompadour rendre visite au duc de
luynes
j'ai proposé notre majesté le roi louis
15 de venir se promener prendre un peu
l'air dans le château est donc dans le
parc que de mon domaine de dampierre
donc il doit être quelque part dans les
jardins en train de se promener avec
madame la marquise de pompadour
cette scène est une reconstitution d'une
visite royale s'est organisée à
l'occasion des plaisirs de dampierre des
24 et 25 juillet dernier pour rester
fidèle à l'histoire le domaine de
dampierre a travaillé pendant sept mois
avec une association
on a travaillé avec l'association les
temps passé qu'une association
versaillaise qui est très respectueuse
de des consignes qu'on lui donne
notamment pour celles ci
puisqu'aujourd'hui on reconstitue une
journée de visite royale dehors pour de
l'année 1748 une reco constitution qui
est basée sur les textes écrits par le
duc de luynes puisqu'il était le
mémorialiste de l'oukase personnage
costumes tout y est
même les jeux de l'époque sont
reconstitués pour ce groupe d'amis c'est
une belle découverte
vraiment je vais éclater aujourd'hui ce
parc du château de dampierre est
magnifique on s'y sent bien
c'est très familial très conviviale
c'est sympa mais je trouve sympa en plus
avec les personnes en costume foncé très
très très sympa une première édition des
plaisirs de dampierre qui tend à devenir
un rendez vous chaque été